toujours en direct jusqu'à 19h sur TVfil
pour ce plateau spécial consacré au
journées du patrimoine avec Marie
laurestigard conservatrice du musée de
la ville Catherine junges directrice
adjointe du service enfin des archives
départemental et puis nous a rejoint
aussi sur ce plateau François boulet
bonsoir vous êtes professeur agrégé
docteur en histoire président de la
Fédération des sociétés historiques et
archéologique des zivelines vous avez
publié différents ouvrages notamment
histoire des zivelin qu'est-ce qui vous
passionne autant dans le patrimoine des
ivelines tout c'est un patrimoine riche
justement par rapport aux autres
départements exement localement
départementalement c'est un on appelle
ça l'ancien West de la scèneoise et cet
ouest parisien est depuis au moins le
16e siècle le lieu des châteaux al bien
sans parler du Moyen-Âge mais du château
du 16e et du 17e siècle hein versaill
avant versaill et et c'est le lieu des
forêts ancestrales mais aussi dans
patrimoine mise en valeur via
l'agriculture via l'urbanisation via les
archives départementales au lieu de pour
la recherche et pour la lecture de de
cette richissime bibliographie sur
l'histoire des Ilin vous parlez de la
richesse du patrimoine mais assez ancien
au milieu de tout ça Saint-Quentin
oniveline doit rougir est en retrait
comment vous vous positionnez à
Saint-Quentin enivline quand on parle
patrimoine justement est-ce que
saint-quentineline vient pas forcément
voilà alors comment est-ce que vous
pouvez absolument pas parce que nous on
revendique à la fois d'avoir une
histoire ancienne et d'illeurs dans la
programmation des journées du patrimoine
ont fait toute une programmation sur les
ce qu'on appelait à la quête des relites
de de Saint-Quentin l'histoire de comme
pourquoi est-ce qu' aujourd'hui
s'appelle Saint-Quentin et on s'aperçoit
que ça remonte à une histoire
extrêmement ancienne que vous pouvez
venir découvrir avec le musée de la
ville et donc la particularité de notre
territoire c'est justement de réussir à
conjuguer à faire dialoguer l'ancien et
le et le très récent et d'ailleurs le le
le la belle ville d'arrêt d'histoire
qu'on a obtenu on l'a effectivement
obtenu grâce à la mise en valeur du
patrimoine contemporain mais c'est aussi
parce qu'on avait un patrimoine ancien
qui existait que ce soit effectivement
viens de parler de de Port Royal mais
également les rigoles qui alimenta le
château de Versailles et cetera on a
énormément de patrimoines anciens
peut-être moins connu la commanderie des
templ qu'on vient de voir également on a
beaucoup de patrimoines anciens donc et
aujourd'hui dans notre programmation on
essaie de mêler le patrimoine ancien le
patrimoine contemporain et on y arrive
et on parlera justement tout à l'heure
d'une ville particulièrement sur
cantsveline c'est la ville de
guillancour qui a une histoire aussi
très riche qui participe à ces journées
du patrimoine la responsable des
archives de la commune notamment sera
avec nous qu'est-ce qui différencie le
département des Yvelines des autres
départements peut-être en question de
patrimoine sur cette notion de
patrimoine sa richesse enfin bon
d'autres départements sont riches bien
entendu mais sa richesse parce
que tout le nord la présence de la scène
a beaucoup structuré le département et
puis bien entendu la présence royale he
qui commence qui ne se limite pas à
Versailles évidemment je ne parlerai que
de Saint-Germain en lait mais voilà
voilà ce qui explique la richesse du
département alors justement comment vous
travaillez sur C cette richesse du
département quel est le travail des les
archives départementales au milieu de
tout ça collecter le patrimoine écrit
qui va venir documenter expliquer euh
toute l'histoire de ce patrimoine bâti
que que nous évoquons euh du Moyen-Âge
avec cette chapelle dont nous parlions
tout à l'heure à aujourd'hui puisque
nous avons par exemple dans nos fonds
d'archives c'est comme ça qu'on parle
hein euh les archives de leepa de
Saint-Quentin l'établissement public qui
a aménagé le territoire de la ville donc
nous sommes extrêmement complémentaires
euh les uns des autres et cela il verait
pour Saint-Quentin et cela il verait
pour l'ensemble du territoire quels sont
les documents les plus anciens dont vous
disposez est-ce qu'il y a des des
trésors justement du patrimoine de la
richesse oui alors le document le plus
ancien c'est un document qui date du 9e
siècle ouis quand même Charles lechau
c'est un acte du roi Charles lechauve
qui est en fait le petit-fils de
charlesemne et qui hérite après le
partage de Verdin le traité de Verdin
qui hérite de la France occidentale
c'est en fait si vous voulez le pour
schématiser le premier roi de France VO
voilà donc nous avons un acte signé par
lui voici le je juste faire tout de
suite une parenthèse durant les journées
du patrimoine les archives
départementales le site ne sera pas
ouvert au public non parce que nous
sommes ouverts tous les jours de la
semaine un Sam par mois et que c'est
ouvert à tout public qui veut venir
consulter des Arch monde peut venir tout
le monde peut venir et c'est gratuit
attention amenez cependant une pièce
d'identité avec une photographie et mais
vous serez inscrit François boulet vous
travaillez quelque fois aux archives
départementales vous y allez fréquemment
justement pour
ou le plus que l'on peut est-ce que vous
êtes donc le président de la Fédération
des sociétés historiques et
archéologiques des ivelines je lis bien
mes notes pour pas me tromper sur ce C
cette longue ce long titre intitulé ça
signifie quoi justement en quoi consiste
le travail des c'est un VI titre qui
date du 19e siècle c'est la Fédération
anciennement des sociétés historiques du
soyons clair c'est 3000 passionnés
d'histoire locale avec 36
associations pour préserver le
patrimoine mais aussi pour travailler
aux archives dans les bibliothèques sur
les documents les fonds anciens ou à
travers les bâtiments le je j'apprécie
d'ailleurs de parler de modernité parce
que je je crois que la modernité c'est
aussi de de s'intéresser à notre notre
sens historique je crois qu'il y a quand
on se veut être moderne VO se pencher
vers sur le futur je crois que déjà la
première étape une des premières étapes
c'est de connaître notre sens historique
et nous en avons beaucoup ici dans les
disciplines via les archives les
associations historiques vous parliez
3000 passionnés justement est-ce que
c'est un nombre grandissant parler
brièvement tout à l'heure de
l'engouement autour du patrimoine est-ce
que justement vous vous le voyez vous le
constatez de plus en plus de gens
veulent connaître leur histoire
connaître le le patrimoine d'un
département où où ils sont installés
grâce à vous je veux bien avoir de 6000
demain vous allez doubler nombre de
personnes qui s'y intéresse mais en tout
cas est-ce que c'est le cas ces
dernières années est-ce qu' voilà un
retour aux sources un petit peu on sent
qu'on cherche nos racin voilà ça
assurément hein ce recherche du sens se
recherche de la clarté en nous par
rapport à nos origines par rapport à ce
mot qui un peu tarte à la crème quion
appelle l'identité indéiablement via les
via notamment la généalogie via via les
recherches historiques maintenant
l'histoire elle-même la recherche de la
vérité historique avec des sources je ne
sais pas si nous sommes plus maintenant
qu'il y a 50 ans je ne sais pas si
notamment l'historiographie locale je
souhaiterais qu'elle soit encore plus
vivante et si je suis là c'est que je
souhaite qu'il a encore plus d'amateurs
et vous allez participer au journé du
patrimoine pour justement attirer encore
plus d'amateurs participer avec une
conférence bu blio s an d'histoire 1912
2012 samedi 15 septembre à 16h
parlez-nous un petit peu de cette
conférence et et de l'exposition qui va
avec aussi il y a une exposition alors
là c'est me semble le cœur de deselin
est aussi alors aussi modernité c'est la
la naissance de l'aviation or il se
trouve qu'à Buc au haut Buc vous avez un
ancien Aéroparc qui a été créé fondé par
quasiment par fondé par Louis Blerot
alors je rappelle qui Louis Blerot c'est
tout de même le premier aviateur en tous
les cas un Aéroplan on disait pas
aviateur à l'époque sur Aéroplan à faire
33 minutes 33 km c'est facile à retenir
entre sangat et douve en juillet 1909 et
donc cette ce génie de l'aviation
pendant 20 ans a organisé un aérodrome
qui est devenu un centre de de de
propagation de de de l'aviation d'abord
avec la la Première Guerre mondiale
indéiablement puis les années 20 le
Touring Club de France plus d'un
tourisme d'aviateur jusqu'en jusqu'aux
difficultés des années
30 là la crise étant ce qu'elle est dans
les années 30 et cet Aéroparc va durer
jusqu'en 1966 dans les années 50 60 on a
les fameux premiers hélicoptères
notamment du gouvernement français 4e
République et 5e République qui sont
construits dans cet Aéroparc jusqu'en
1966 et vous êtes aussi un passionné
d'aviation ou pas du tout en tout cas
passionné d'histoire je suis allé aux
archives et j'ai commencé à travailler
en tout cas passionné d'histoire on peut
plus vous interrompre une fois vous êtes
parti justement non non c'était juste
pour faire remarquer qu'effectivement
vous deviez effectivement en savoir
beaucoup avoir beaucoup travaillé avec
les archives l'Aéroparc blerio c'est
l'aviation c'est un point important de
l'histoire du département oui c'est un
point important euh notamment à la
période donc dont parlait monsieur
boulet savoir les années juste avant la
Première Guerre mondiale puisqu'on
retrouve là Blerot mais on retrouve
aussi d'autres constructeurs qui
s'installent dans ce dans ce coin là je
veux dire sur le le plateau à versta il
y avait lesil à coublet bien sûr même si
ensuite plus tard on va retrouver des
installations sur la scène mais c'est je
ne m'attarderai pas parce que je vois
bien votre œil varier mais le programme
est riche ce soir ça n'est pas moins
intéressant mais le programme est
effectivement rich moav juste une peti
question le département des isulines
sent pas un peu étouffé par
l'omniprésence et la richesse de Paris
parce qu'on est quand même très proche
de Paris non il y a pas de concurrence
non vraiment pas V je pas la dame a dit
tout à l'heure j'irai à Paris une dame
qui éta parisou à versa elle peut aller
dans les communes environnantes dans le
dans l'ouest de des ivelines dans le sud
des on rester à 5quent en ielin aussi
par exemple aller je pense que c'est
deux offres radicalement différentes il
une offre avec du très grand patrimoine
effectivement on pour aller visiter
l'Élysée ou Matignon si c'est ça qui
vous amuse allez-y c'est vrai que cette
année les Journées du Patrimoine c'était
accé sur les patrimoines cachés je pense
que les patrimoines cachés on en a
peut-être plus à Saint-Quentin que à
l'Élysée merci à François boulet vous
restez sur ce plateau avec nous Marie
lorestinard également du musée de la
ville de Saint-Quentin on va libérer
catherineess des Archives
départementales merci d'être pass c'est
sur ce plateau et puis nous on va
retourner dans les rues ivelinoises avec
toujours cette question votre programme
pour ces journées du patrimoine édition
spéciale sur TVfil du 78 jusqu'à 19h en
direct très régulièrement on y va avec
ma petite femme on adore ça l'année
dernière on avait fait le Louvre encore
une fois et tous les ans fait quelque
chose donc cette année je sais pas
encore ce qu'on va faire mais il y a des
grandes chances qu'on aille sur Paris à
beauourg ou palet Tokyo on verra je sais
pas un amée peut-être j'ai vu une pub
pour un euh le musée du du Forin c'est
un musée qui regroupe des tonnes de
d'objets qui concernent le cirque